bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e siamo
sullo speciale non avrei mai pensato di
dirlo 5 milioni di iscritti
siamo arrivati a 5 milioni ragazzi
questa volta voluto fare le cose
veramente in grande ho organizzato una
festa per il 5 milioni di iscritti alla
quale ho invitato i miei amici i miei
parenti e i miei amici vip
questi sono gli invitati vip alla mia
festa siccome sono così tanti ho dovuto
affittare una location d'eccezione la
villa del buon george che mi ha già
detto che non verrà la festa purtroppo
ma chissenefrega tanto ci sono tutti
loro ai quali consegnerò personalmente
l'invito al mio pigiama party
andiamo a consegnarli
[Musica]
organizzato sta festa no invitato un po
tutti perché 65 milioni li ha fatti
ancora nessuno in italia poi tanta roba
quindi hanno invitato tutta la gente più
importante per me è più importante anche
perché si seguono un sacco di tempo sono
tuo fan quindi volevo darti con questo è
l'invito ufficiale della mia festa mi
vorreste a questa festa per caserme o
fan e vediamo se messe guida un sacco
non faccio un piccolo test vico delle
mie canzoni vediamo se conosci pare la
mia ragazza ti ha lasciato tutto tua
sorella
io non so se tu sai dove sei qui secondo
te uno come me potrebbe mai venire la
tua festa sì
sono venuto a invitarti di persona ti do
direttamente l'invito alla festa ho
fatto 5 milioni su youtube
se vuoi venire e diciamo a parte poi
viene anche così due stanno bene per me
va bene l'unico come vuoi basta che
vieni perché almeno tu già insomma ma
che con le mani alzate
vediamo in giro è sempre un piacere
parlare con voi
un abbraccio a tutti ciò abbiamo finito
no grazie che ottimizzino salvare lo hai
visto bene molto bene
ascoltami ma sai che sto arrivando a 5
milioni di iscritti su youtube sono
tantissimi e sto facendo una festa no
questo l'invito niente quindi io sto
invitando un po tutte le persone che
rappresentano qualcosa per me e ci
tenessi l'unico lorenzis nome tra
l'altro vini fichissimo se se vieni
aveva veramente piacere quindi fare tv
io perché ci sono sempre e ci sarò
tu sei sempre più ma quindi ci viene la
festa no
grazie ciao caro scusami se ti visto no
volevo invitarti semplicemente alla mia
festa far discutere tempo volevo
invitarla questa festa festa galante si
lasciano aspettata una villa gli ospiti
sono proprio ma kit da fitch e gli
ospiti che genera già mangia se si
mangia sia un certo cui fino a cucina
signor canavacciuolo proprio è però una
festa incredibile ma questo è il flyer
per la festa l'invito questo invito si
paga forata disfatta completa di
inizierà portato di questo che mi sa che
mi portavo lì è il lamento
chi è che ha fatto si ebbe liceo fede di
febbraio non sono mete parigi è quell
ora sto facendo una festa perché ho
fatto 5 milioni di iscritti e giovedì
giovedì giovani la faccio giovedì no c'è
il podologo ma come mai vi guarda
aspetta un pacco da amazon che se lo
stai lì domande che poi ecco ma non è
mai
tu mi inviti che dirigono succede al
ricorso di una conseguente c'è qualcuno
di prima a dire chi è cioè non è che
così io pensavo di mattino 5 milioni io
vado lì lo va a torino
ti posso dire preferisco il podologo
frank tutto a posto
si scherza e occupato volevo
semplicemente chiederti siccome ho fatto
5 milioni di iscritti
quando hai tempo sono organizzando una
festa e mi piacerebbe molto che tu
facessi parte di questa festa
sai ci divertiamo a venire e non vado
più alle feste a se questa è la mia vita
ora a sé sicuro ma guarda che è una
bella feci divertiamo poi ci sono un
sacco di macchine belle semi bhatti
vengo se si battono in che senso ha
paura della velocità
[Musica]
va bene lei te la do vinto sei più
allenato ascolta dai parte gli scherzi
ci vieni non ho la mia festa no essere
questa cosa va bene franchi non lo sai
che ti dico
abbiamo iniziato su youtube dove il
percorso non ci siamo rivisti nel posto
che ci siamo visti la prima volta io
sono contento non è la prima volta che
ci vediamo
e anche l'ultima
e così è un onore ma un piacere averti
nel mio pigiama party 75 milioni di
iscritti sono veramente veramente tanti
ti do il mio invito
l'invito del party c'è scritto che sei
invitato ci vieni alla mia festa no
no noi non mangiavo non mangiava gabri
grande stand chi ascolta un attimo io
sto facendo una festa per i miei 5
milioni di iscritti no è piaciuto
iscritti di youtube youtube è presente
su youtube si faccia ogni tanto video
per hobby sentiva comunque sto facendo
cinque gli anni iscritti faccio la festa
al mio pigiama party volevano imitarti
queste flyer
ma non solo se riesco a venire tra due
giorni non riesci ma io c'ho antonio del
furgone o tra due giorni che mi piace
venire si sia giocato però devo fare la
festa non posso dire niente
facciamo così sembra un ragazzo lascia
il tuo numero certo forse riesco a
venire ma ha giocato sente si si io ho
giocato bene se vengo ti chiamo grazie
ciao
non ci credo non ci posso veramente
credere sono lorenzo mi presento già
faccio 5 milioni di iscritti su youtube
il mio club ha portato lei lorenzo e no
no no no non sono il cameriere io sono
uno youtuber faccio uno eyoutube youtube
ci hai presente quella roba lì è
comunque sta organizzando questa festa
su youtube e quindi volevo invitarti
insomma perché secondo me trattori poi
ci si conosce trattori ci conosciamo
io faccio gli utenti hanno fatto anche
un film che in terapie presente comunque
se vuoi venire alla mia festa questo è
l'invito senti
fa vj hem a seconda del violento la tua
maestà si
[Musica]
raga alla fine ha deciso che non la
facciamo più nella villa di george
perché se non era un po troppo grande e
poi troppo sfarzoso la facciamo a casa
mia direttamente ok ci vediamo dopo ci
siete
dai che ci divertiamo ciao lore alla
fine imposto problemi perché sono almeno
una vittoria di vertice
un maglione giallo io mi spiace mi ero
dimenticato ciò la cena con la squadra è
meno a meno di brutto pagarli alla
prossima
bella ciao amore e noi non possiamo
venire la festa perché dovevo portare il
samba a fare l'attuale dettatura
ok un bacio d'amore ci sentiamo ciao
acs almeno tu vieni no
[Musica]
pronto ciao sono poco dopo quindi vieni
tu la festa no non vengono riesco così
come sembra un ragazzo fare una sorpresa
a dimmiquando mio amico cristiano
cristiano tesoro ma è qui la festa
vuoi spiegare una cosa facciamo parte e
non sapevo purtroppo in un po più
già ma non fornì no no no no perché io
vado a dormire sempre il modo michael
bay stop
[Musica]
pelle a tutti ragazzi venuti a questo
primissimo video del canale di parigi e
tv
siamo a quota di chi e qi milita già
comunicata nel cervello ma sono ancora
vivo pedala pedala vuole ringraziare per
questo traguardo incredibile 37 mi ha
dato l'autorizzazione di famiglia gara
tosta e sullo speciale 45 mila iscritti
grazie mille numero assurdo
volevo ringraziarvi di cuore per il 50
mila iscritti vanta cifre misti
i 150.000
300 mila iscritti
e diamo finalmente recassimo speciale di
un milione di iscritti dei reni
i ragazzi abbiamo raggiunto i 2 milioni
d'iscritti che un traguardo che non mi
sarei mai niente
sognate
[Musica]
ma vi chiedo sei
no volevo immischiarmi cuore perché
guardi sono 4 milioni
[Musica]
raga io siamo arrivati ai 5 milioni è
ormai non è più una questione di numeri
io sono contentissimo di tutto questo di
tutto quello che si è creato del
divertimento delle persone che ho
conosciuto e sono qui al termine di
questo video per ringraziare tutti
coloro che mi hanno supportato primis
voglio ringraziare la mia famiglia mia
mamma mio papà che mi sono sempre stati
vicino nel è il mash up che e motional
ok mi sono sempre stati vicino al sin
dall'inizio mi hanno sempre supportato
quindi io non potrei desiderare dei
genitori migliori di quelli che ho
voglio ringraziare i miei fan tutti dal
primo iscritto al 5 milionesimo perché
mi hanno sempre supportato mi avete
sempre supportato in tutte le occasioni
e per me questo vuol dire tantissimo al
di là dei numeri proprio l'affetto che
che ci unisce
oltre qualsiasi cosa per me è veramente
tanta tanta tanta roba
come ultimo ma non meno importante
vorrei ringraziare il mio team quindi
web star channel che negli ultimi anni
mi ha aiutato a realizzare progetti è
stata dietro perché sono strappi grow
quindi sono sempre sul pezzo e vorrei
ringraziarli veramente di cuore per lo
splendido lavoro che stanno svolgendo
che hanno svolto che svolgeranno come
ultima persona vorrei ringraziare mio
fratello mio fratello lorenzo che mi ha
insegnato tanto
negli ultimi quattro anni ci conosciamo
da quattro anni lavora con me ma per me
non è soltanto un collaboratore è un
amico e nel tempo è diventato un
fratello vero fratello non ci unisce
allo stesso sangue ma ci uniscono le
stesse ideologie ci divertiamo
lavoriamo insieme e per me è un piacere
lavorare con certe persone che mi
ispirano ogni giorno di più
questa è la vita dei 5 milioni ragazze
spero che video vi sia piaciuto come al
suo video piacere lasciare un commento
è un mi piace anche vari stage anche
come non li vedo trattarne descrizione
se non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi
e noi ci rivediamo come sempre ad un
prossimo video bella ragazzi